bonjour à tous nous sommes très heureux
de vous retrouver avec philippe juvin et
georges fenech pour ce point presse
hebdomadaire à ses dents sur des
thématiques à la fois locale nationale
et internationale avec un agenda
européen c'est important cher philippe
vous commencez d'abord par les
problématiques et les questions d'agenda
donc le outre le point presse ce matin
le président des républicains nicolas
sarkozy est actuellement dans l'est dans
les départements du haut-rhin et du
territoire de belfort à fessenheim entre
autres demain il recevra en entretien à
11 heures l'ensemble des syndicats de de
police puis se déroulera la commission
exécutive à 18 heures il interviendra le
soir même lors du colloque du think tank
la france fière et puis nous aurons
mercredi prochain dans le prolongement
de l'ensemble des conventions organisées
sur le programme de notre formation
politique depuis plusieurs mois une
grande matinée de travail consacrée à la
protection sociale et à la santé et
enfin en fin de semaine nicolas sarkozy
s'envolera pour l'île de la réunion
toujours dans le cadre de ses
déplacements et ses fonctions de
président des républicains
deuxièmement nous voulions tous les
trois au nom de notre formation
politique nous réjouir des résultats des
élections partielles de dimanche des
deux élections partielles législatives
qui se sont déroulées dans l'est et dans
le sud particulièrement dans les
alpes-maritimes dans la circonscription
de christian estrosi avec l'excellent
score réalisé au premier tour par notre
candidate avec près de 48% des suffrages
dès le premier tour mais elle améliore
le score de notre famille politique par
rapport à 2012
nous affronterons le
front national au second tour dans cette
circonscription et nous réjouir aussi du
maintien de notre score dans la
circonscription de strasbourg où nous
nous positionnons à la deuxième place et
nous affronterons le candidat du parti
socialiste dans une circonscription
historiquement de gauche
donc nous sommes ce matin-là une fois de
plus sa seule formation politique à être
qualifié au second tour des deux
élections partielles qui se dérouleront
dimanche prochain enfin sur les grandes
thématiques qui nous concernent et qui
est évidemment préoccupe nos
compatriotes avant de laisser la parole
un philippin et un georges vous voyez
combien là encore dans le prolongement
de ce qu'a exprimé nicolas sarkozy lors
du 20 heures de tf1 hier avec beaucoup
de justesse et de et de force
nous sommes dans un moment très
compliqué pour notre pays
très préoccupant pour nos compatriotes
et je dirais que le gouvernement le
présent la république le premier
ministre continue après le jeu du
mensonge
après le jeu de l'incompétence après le
jeu de l'aveuglément
il vient d'inventer une nouvelle façon
de faire de la politique en se livrant
au jeu du déni avec un tango très
hésitant le lundi ça va mieux
le vendredi ça va bien si l'on écoute
par exemple secrétaire d'état aux
transports sur la question des du
carburant il faut être profondément
déconnecté de la réalité de notre pays
ne rien connaître des préoccupations de
nos compatriotes et de leurs angoisses
pour oser dire par exemple sur la
question du carburant que tout va bien
tout le monde c'est parce que tout le
monde vit depuis plusieurs jours
cette pénurie de carburant sur une
grande partie du territoire
pas seulement la normandie par seulement
le grand ouest de clermont ferrand
au nord en passant par chez moi par
exemple la sologne
encore ce matin dans ma commune ya plus
de diesel et de nombreux français
doivent effectuer de nombreux
déplacements pour trouver de l'essence
donc il faut qu'on arrête
il faut que le gouvernement arrête de
raconter n'importe quoi à nos
compatriotes et une fois de plus plutôt
que de commenter dans l'angélisme et le
déni la situation économique et sociale
que connaît notre pays nous nous
demandons les républicains une action
forte ferme efficace et réactive en
appliquant la loi tout simplement comme
l'avait fait courageusement le
gouvernement avec nicolas ça il françois
fillon et brice hortefeux à l'automne
2010 nous demandons ce matin à ce que le
gouvernement prenne des mesures fortes
pour libérer les raffineries pour mettre
fin au blocus et pour réquisitionner si
nécessaire les personnels comme le rend
possible le code général de la des
collectivités territoriales c'est
possible c'est nécessaire c'est utile et
s'est demandé par nos compatriotes le
droit de grève est certes un droit
fondamental mais qui ne doit pas
s'opposer à un droit tout aussi
fondamental qui est celui d'aller et
venir librement et de travailler les
français souhaitent pouvoir travailler
et dans ce contexte nous demandons au
gouvernement d'agir avec force et
autorités pour libérer l'ensemble des
raffineries actuellement bloqués
deuxièmement vous l'avez entendu hier et
on répondra évidemment à vos questions
sur ces sujets nous saluons aussi la
force de proposition nicolas sarkozy qui
par delà le simple constat et
commentaires auxquels nous habitue trop
souvent nos responsables politiques sur
la situation de notre pays lui a fait
des propositions fortes et claires dès
hier soir pour mettre fin non pas à ce
sentiment mais à cette réalité
d'anarchie et de laxisme qui gangrène
notre pays qui gangrène le pacte
républicain
jour après jour les français n'en
peuvent plus de ces images
répétition de ces scènes de violences à
répétition de cette réalité qui en plus
des images qui font le tour du monde et
qui donne une image d'un pays à
l'abandon est totalement oubliée et
abandonné par ses responsables
politiques donc que ce soit par la
proposition de peine plancher
automatique pour tous ceux qui
s'attaquent aux forces de l'ordre que ce
soit par la responsabilité civile
c'est-à-dire financière pour tous les
organisateurs de manifestations qui
connaissent des débordements nous avons
tous le souvenir on en parlait ce matin
qu'en 2013 par exemple donc nouvel
exemple du deux poids deux mesures la
mairie de paris n'avait pas hésité à
envoyer aux organisateurs de la manif
pour tous pourtant sans aucun
débordement
la facture pour une remise en état des
lieux de manifestation il est très
étonnant
cent mille euros pour une somme de cent
mille euros quand même il est très
étonnant de ne pas voir la mairie de
nantes où la mairie de paris a dressé
les mêmes facture aux organisateurs des
manifestations qui connaissent de
nombreux débordements depuis de très
longues semaines
donc nous dénonçons aussi ce deux poids
deux mesures et nous demandons et au
gouvernement et aux élus de ces villes
là d'avoir la même cohérence et la même
logique concernant ces débordements
récents
nous demandons aussi troisième
proposition nicolas sarkozy et des
républicains la dissolution des groupes
d'extrême gauche qui sont connues pour
leur violence pour leurs agissements
pour leur type d'organisation il faut
avoir la même fermeté à l'endroit de ces
groupes violents d'extrême gauche que
les gouvernements précédents put avons
pu avoir à l'endroit des groupes
d'extrême droite
et puis enfin nicolas sarkozy l'a bien
exprimé aussi lors de
journal télévisé nous souhaitons
l'interdiction l'interdiction préventive
des casseurs qui sont fichés à l'exemple
de ce qui existe pour les hooligans des
stades de football qu'ils puissent être
identifiés ils ont identifié mais qui
plus est repensé moment en amendes et
des manifestations entendu par les
forces de police et de gendarmerie et
empêcher formellement est
fondamentalement de se rendre dans ces
manifestations et de poursuivre leurs
agissements parce que le sentiment
d'impunité de laxisme et d'anarchie ne
peut plus perdurer dans notre pays il
est temps de réhabiliter et de rétablir
avec force l'autorité de l'état
c'est le sens des propositions que
nicolas sarkozy a porté tout au long de
la soirée que nous continuerons à
développer dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent cher philippe j'essaie
d'être synthétique vient écouter sur les
questions européennes actualité
peut-être cinq points a souligné
premier point le feuilleton turc avec la
question des visas
nous sommes manifestement en face à une
grande entreprise de tromperie à la fois
des turcs
je veux développer mais aussi du
président de la république et madame
merkel sur les turcs d'abord je vous
rappelle ce chiffre que je vous ai donné
la dernière fois il ya deux mois le 4
mars turc remplissait 19 critères sur 72
pour obtenir la libéralisation des visas
et par miracle la magie en deux mois on
prétend qu aujourd'hui il remplit 67 de
ses 72 critères la réalité c'est qu'aux
républicains nous sommes persuadés que
les critères ne sont pas remplis mais
que pour des raisons politiques une
commande politique la commission
européenne affirme que des critères en
réalité pas bien remplie le sont parce
que on nous sommes sous la coupe de
monsieur erdogan qui exige la
libéralisation des critères et
manifestement la commission européenne
avec la complicité des grands états la
france y joue son jeu est en train de
tordre le bras au droit européen et ça
l'est républicain ne l'acceptent pas et
puis monsieur hollande nous explique
d'un autre côté qu'il va s'opposer à
libéralisation des visas
si les fameux critères ne sont pas
remplies outre le fait que tout le monde
sait que les critères ne seront pas
remplies
même si les 67 sont considérés comme
remplie le manque de toute façon 5 et ce
sont cinq critères inatteignable en
quelques semaines il faut des passeports
biométriques et turcs n'ont pas il faut
une législation sur la protection des
données
les turcs ne l'ont pas il faut une
définition du terrorisme qui souhaitent
une définition qui répondent aux
critères des droits de l'homme de
l'union européenne les turcs ne l'auront
pas et donc on voit bien que d'un côté
le président l'an nous dit ah mais vous
ne vous inquiétez pas nous ne libéralise
rompt pas les visas turc
tant que les critères ne seront pas fait
mais en même temps nous apprenons la
semaine dernière que la france avec
l'allemagne vient de proposer à la
commission d'adopter une disposition
d'un mécanisme de suspension des visas
d'une manière automatique autrement dit
on est en train de préparer l'opinion
grâce à ce type de procédure en disant
attention on est en train de mettre des
filets de sécurité à une libéralisation
des visas qui si elle n'arrive pas au
mois de juin arrivera dès la rentrée en
septembre octobre quand les français ne
seront pas encore tout à fait prêt à
sortir de vacances donc nous sommes nous
les républicains évidemment opposés à
cette libéralisation des visas pour ces
raisons juridiques mais aussi pour des
raisons politiques
comment va-t-on dire alors que nous
sommes face à une crise migratoire
immense et oui nous ouvrons les visas à
80 millions de turcs tout ça est
absolument dément deuxième point un
point de remarques qui est un peu passé
inaperçu sur la question de l'arbitrage
privé
vous savez que sur le taffetas traité
transatlantique
un des points de discussion c'était
faut-il ou pas des tribunaux arbitraux
soi-disant privé pour régler les
différends entre les états et des
entreprises privées et les socialistes
en france et hollande et le président
hollande également disait nous jamais
nous ne voulons pas de ces tribunaux
soit et on s'aperçoit en même temps
c'est le monde qui a publié
l'information dans une document très
complet la semaine dernière qu' un
certain nombre de pays dont la france et
l'allemagne comme par hasard défendent
ces mêmes tribunes au privé pour ce qui
est de la règlement des différends à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
je m'explique il y actuellement plus de
200 traité d'un bilatéraux entre les
états membres qui sont souvent des vieux
traité qui date d'avant l'élargissement
entre la france et la pole
entre l'allemagne et l'espagne les
choses qu'ont parfois 30 ans et ses
traités il faut les mines il faut il
faut faire faire il faut 3 les telle
affaire puisqu'il ya maintenant un
marché unique eh bien la france et
l'allemagne demandent que ces traités
soit annulée au bénéfice du marché
unique et ça nous partageons évidemment
cet avis ils ne servent plus à rien en
revanche la france dit gouvernement
français dit oui mais nous voulons
garder un mécanisme de règlement des
différends investiture est états sur la
base de ce règlement ces tribunaux
arbitraux donc il ya vraiment deux poids
deux mesures dans la sphère du taffetas
parce qu'ils en font une affaire
politique de comme ils disent on ne veut
pas de ces tribunaux mais dans une
affaire plus discrète au fond
l'attention des médias n'est pas
focalisé on s'aperçoit que le
gouvernement tient un double un double
langage
troisième point concernant l'actualité
sur le détachement des travailleurs vous
savez fameuse question de plombier
polonais on nous bassine depuis dix ans
avec cette affaire là actuellement nous
avons demandé un certain nombre de
groupes politiques ont demandé à la
commission de mettre de l'ordre dans
cette affaire parce que nous voulons
plus de ce dumping salarial et social et
donc il ya une proposition actuellement
sur le bureau du parlement qui vient
d'arriver ou la commission dit nous
allons modifier les règles juridiques et
en particulier nous allons instituer une
règle qui est à travail égal salaire
égal
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui un
travailleurs détachés qui vient par
exemple de pologne qui travaillent en
france n'a pas à toucher le même salaire
qu'un ouvrier français ou un employé
français qui fait le même travail
la loi dit simplement il faut lui verser
le salaire minimum ce que nous voulons
nous c'est qu'à travail égal salaire
égal bref mettre fin au dumping salarial
donc nous défendons cette affaire nous
espérons la faire passer au parlement
européen il se trouve qu'il y à une
procédure tout à fait inédite qui a été
inaugurée la semaine dernière par un
certain nombre d'états c'est ce qu'on
appelle la procédure du carton jaune
avant l'euro ça tombe bien mais le
carton jaune c'est quand 19 états
souhaitent à dire des états par un tiers
des parlements nationaux considère que
la subsides arias subsidiarité n'est pas
bien respecté et met en cause la
décision de la commission européenne
donc évidemment
ce sont essentiellement des pays de
l'est qui fournissent des travailleurs
détachés qui veulent s'opposer à cette
procédure de la commission qui veut
imposer à travail égal salaire égal et
donc nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
français s'oppose évidemment à cette
procédure de carton jaune mais nous
sommes particulièrement inquiets puisque
ça fait maintenant deux semaines que la
procédure est lancée et le gouvernement
français n'a toujours pas expliqué
qu'elle était son choix nous espérons
qu'ils que le gouvernement nous défendra
dans cette affaire du salaire égal et
travail égal un point sur europol lors
de la dernière séance du parlement
européen nous avons voté un modification
du fonctionnement d'europol vous savez
europol c'est un service intégré de
police j'enchaînais connaissait beaucoup
mieux que moi qui consiste à permettre
d'échanger des informations plus qu'en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
notre talon d'achille c'est l'absence d'
échanges d'informations et donc dans la
disposition législative que nous avons
votée nous avons renforcé la coopération
entre les états membres et bien d'une
manière très surprenante
il ya deux groupes au parlement européen
qui ont voté contre cet échange
renforcer d'informations sûres sur les
communistes et le front national le
front national s'oppose à cette
intégration plus grande échanges
d'informations pour des raisons qui sont
en fait assez clair c'est que poussant
une sorte de nationalisme exacerbé et
aveugle et d'isolationnisme eh bien on
en arrive à des positions aussi absurde
qui consiste à dire finalement on ne va
pas donner nos informations à nos
voisins et d'ailleurs et donc du coup
nous ne voulons pas des informations de
nos voisins tout ça est absolument
évidemment absurde
un mot enfin sur l'autriche vous avec
l'élection présidentielle a eu lieu on
n'a pas encore les résultats alors
laquelle je vous parle parce qu'il ya 14
pour cent des bulletins de vote des
autrichiens de l'étranger qui restent à
dépouiller
dans tous les cas de toute façon cette
affaire est très claire elle témoigne de
quoi et quand vous n'avez pas le choix
entre la doc ou droite et la gauche
c'est à dire qu'on la droite et la
gauche c'est pareil quand ya pas de
différence dans les affirmations
politique quand on gouverne ensemble
en autriche les socialistes est
l'équivalent des républicains gouverne
sur 69 ans ont gouverné 39 ans 39 ans
semble donc
lippert relativisme que cela crée
l'absence de différence conduit à ce
genre de choix des autrichiens qui
finalement n'en peuvent plus et 10 au
fond nous voulons essayer autre chose et
donc nous attirons l'attention
républicains sur le fait que ceux qui
prétendent dans notre famille politique
et d'autres dire qu'au fond tout ça
c'est pareil la droite et la gauche n'a
plus de n'y a plus de différence
on pourrait très bien gouverner avec les
uns et les autres attention à ce type
d'affirmation qui parfois peut être vrai
réellement mais qui fait courir un
risque c'est celui de l'hyper
relativisme il ya plus de différence et
quand vous voyez ça et vous apercevez
que les autrichiens sont perdus la
deuxième raison elle est lié aussi au
fait que les grands partis
les socialistes en particulier gouverne
avec l'extrême droite là bas dans des
régions il ya une des régions leburgue
irlande qui est dirigé par l'extrême
droite et les socialistes autrichiens
qui siège au parlement européen avec les
socialistes français donc notre refus de
compter avec le l'extrême droite en
france c'est aussi une un filet de
sécurité contre l'émergence de ses
hypers un nationaliste et enfin dernière
points il faut comprendre les
autrichiens cet appel 8 millions
d'habitants
ils ont neuf cent mille réfugiés ils ont
20 81 cents milles 90 mille réfugiés et
ils ont vu passer à leurs portes un
million de personnes qui étaient
déplacés perdues dont d'ailleurs
monsieur timmermans je rappelle à
travers clairement dit qu'il y en a au
moins 60 % qui sont ici rien ni réfugiés
politiques ils sont que des réfugiés
économiques
eh bien les autrichiens face à cette
absence totale d'europe
incapable de juguler les flux
d'immigration on arrive à voter ce
qu'ils ont voté donc la question elle
est clair c'est qu'il faut de la clarté
dans les positions politiques
il faut des différences entre la droite
et la gauche et puis il faut que
l'europe soit apte à juguler les flux
d'immigration et vous savez que lors de
la convention europe de la semaine
dernière le président de mouvement
nicolas sarkozy a clairement appelé de
ses voeux la création d'un nouveau champ
gagnent d'un euro chagan plus intégré
plus efficace sur lesquels nous
pourrions revenir si vous le souhaitez
voilà sur l'actualité européenne
dont renault en france pour parler de du
texte qui sera soumis demain au vote à
l'assemblée nationale par scrutin public
sur ce qui a été appelé intitulée
pompeusement la modernisation de la
justice du 21e siècle il y avait été je
rappelle initiée par christiane taubira
les républicains votre contre ce projet
même avec la meilleure des bonnes
volontés ne considérons que ce projet ne
répond en rien ou quasiment en rien aux
besoins d'une justice qui est
aujourd'hui totalement exsangues
j'aime étant d'abord des vives critiques
sur le choix de la procédure accélérée
quand on prépare la justice pour tout le
siècle qui vient on aurait pu laisser le
temps au débat à la réflexion
alors que depuis son passage au sénat le
texte végéter sur le bureau de
l'assemblée depuis le mois de novembre
on s'étonne aussi que s'élèverait
quelques vrais sujets comme le divorce
par consentement mutuel ou bien la
suppression de même les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs sont arrivés
sont nés en commission des lois ou par
le détour d'un amendement gouvernemental
en pleine navette parlementaire c'est
j'y vois un truc hallucine que loin de
proposer de vision cohérente ensemble
réfléchi acceptée par l'ensemble des
acteurs d'injustice ce projet socialiste
n'était qu'un patchwork un ensemble de
mesures disparates même même si prises
une à une
certaines vont dans le bon sens à
l'instar de celles favorisant par
exemple la médiation ou la conciliation
en amont du procès ussel j'ai noté
créant un corps de juristes assistant
pour épauler le travail des magistrats
en définitive il s'agit pour nous d'une
occasion manquée pour une réforme
d'envergure éloigné de toute idéologie
tels que l'attendent les françaises
rappellent à sondage du csa de mars 2014
77% des français considèrent que la
justice fonctionne mal et d'après le
cevif hop ils sont seulement 44% avoir
confiance dans le système judiciaire
alors trois points d'abord sur un plan
matériel
la justice nous savons et en l'état
d'apoplexie l'ensemble des experts au
premier desquels le garde des sceaux
actuelle
jean jacques urvoas s'accordent pour
souligner que le budget de la justice
devrait pratiquement être le double de
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui pour rejoindre
le standard des grands pays européens
comparables l'allemagne notamment
jean jacques urvoas a évoqué lui même
une justice je le cite en voie de
clochardisation donc incapable de payer
ses fournisseurs même s'il a obtenu une
rallonge récente d'un million de francs
d'un million d'euros 200 millions
d'euros par conte pardon qui va en
réalité permettent de payer les arriérés
incapable de payer des fournisseurs
incapable d'entretenir ces bâtiments
incapable de faire fonctionner ses
photocopieurs on en est là donc nous
dénonçons vraiment avec la plus grande
fermeté cet aveuglement de françois
hollande et de christiane taubira qui
ont laissé s'aggraver cette situation
sans réagir véritablement même s'il est
vrai que cette situation remonte à
plusieurs décennies je dirai au moins
une trentaine d'années mais plutôt que
de se lancer dans des réformes teintée
d'idéologie il aurait fallu s'attaquer
aux vrais problèmes que rencontre la
justice aujourd'hui
donc pour répondre au déficit chronique
abyssal du budget de la justice
il est impératif nous semble-t-il que
dès le début du prochain quinquennat
s'engage un véritable plan pluriannuel
pour mettre la justice française au
niveau européen c'est à dire atteindre
le doublement du budget actuel cet
objectif est d'autant plus atteignable
que s'ils ont redéfini le périmètre des
missions de la justice et nous l'avons
déjà annoncé lors de la convention
consacrée à la sécurité
nous avons l'intention de proposer le
détachement de l'administration
pénitentiaire du ministère de la justice
vers le ministère de l'intérieur
donc quand nous parlons du budget de la
justice sera le budget effectivement des
tribunaux
deuxième point en ce qui concerne la
justice pénale
le système pénal dans son ensemble est
en faillite faute de moyens faute
organisation efficiente et plus encore
faute d'une volonté politique plutôt que
de renforcer les moyens de lutte contre
la délinquance
à un moment je le rappelle la menace
terroriste est des plus élevés eh bien
on nous propose tout simplement la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs par pure idéologie
ce qui renvoie un très très mauvais
signal à la délinquance des mineurs la
plus endurcis je rappelle que un crime
ou délit sur cinq aujourd'hui quasiment
est le fait d'un mineur donc face à
cette dérive qui menace l'avenir de
notre jeunesse et de notre société comme
pistes de réforme
nous proposerons évidemment dans les
semaines qui viennent avec plus de
précision une refonte totale je dis bien
une refonte totale de l'ordonnancé de
1945 qui a déjà subi rappelons le en
vain je dirais une soixantaine de
lifting depuis la fin de la guerre et
nous envisageons la création d'un
véritable code des mineurs avec un
abaissement de la majorité pénale à
l'âge de 16 ans en transférant également
c'est le deuxième grand transfert de la
justice à une autre autorité en
transférant tous qui est la protection
civile assistance éducative au conseil
départemental faire du juge des enfants
un véritable juge des mineurs
chargé de réprimer la délinquance des
mineurs conserver un juge des enfants
qui n'interviendra que pour trancher des
conflits entre l'administration et les
faits face à l'abandon sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande du
programme de construction par ailleurs
de 20000 places de prison on ne peut pas
on ne peut que comprendre l'état
aujourd'hui de l'exécution des peines un
qui souffre actuellement d'environ cent
mille peines de prison en attente d'être
d'être mise à exécution ce qui n'est
évidemment pas acceptable qui renforce
ce sentiment d'impunité des délinquants
et qui explique aussi l'explosion des
chiffres de la délinquance
donc nous sommes nous pour assurer une
véritable exécution des peines pour cela
nous aurons l'occasion donc au moment de
la présentation du projet général des
républicains de proposé de relancer le
programme immobilier pénitentiaire et
peut-être aussi réfléchir à la création
de nouveaux types d'établissements plus
léger je dirais light qui pourrait être
adossée à des centres pénitentiaires
pour l'exécution de courtes peines il
faudrait aussi peut-être réfléchir en
amont avant que le problème ne se
présente brutalement comme il est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui à créer
de véritables quartiers dédiés et des
cellules et des cellules aménagé pour
recevoir les détenus radicaliser les
plus dangereux il faudra inscrire comme
au fronton il faudra inscrire un grand
principe dans le code pénal
c'est que le le toute sanction doit être
exécuté on va partir de ce principe le
juge d'application des peines ne
devraient plus avoir le pouvoir de
défaire ap initiaux les sanctions
prononcées par les juridictions de
jugement qu'il y ait en cours
d'exécution
un aménagement des peines bien entendu
nous devons conserver le principe
d'individualisation des peines
mais en aucun cas une somme d'erreurs
une exception d'un monde à cet égard que
le juge d'application des peines
puissent tout seul défaire ce qu'une
juridiction collégiale vient de
prononcer donc c'est une des pistes de
réforme que nous proposons avec
également la suppression des réductions
de peines automatiques qui n'ont aucun
sens et la suppression de la contrainte
pénale qui est déjà un échec cuisant et
dont je rappelle qu'elle devrait
s'appliquer à partir du 1er janvier 2007
pour toutes les peines allant jusqu'à 10
ans d'emprisonnement ça couvre donc des
infractions graves comme le trafic de
stupéfiants ou l'association de
malfaiteurs l'idée ce serait également
évidemment de rétablir ces seuils
minimum pour les récidivistes qu'on
appelle les pêches blanches et voir les
étendre également non seulement aux
récidivistes mais également aux
réitérant ce sera des propositions que
nous formulons troisième et dernier
point enfin en ce qui concerne le
renforcement de la dépendance de la
justice à laquelle job très attachés car
sans indépendant injustice il ne peut
pas y avoir de véritable démocratie
nous constatons que la réforme
constitutionnelle
après plusieurs péripéties et il faut
bien le reconnaître morte-née on n'a pas
mobilisé un congrès à versailles
uniquement pour inscrire dans la loi
suprême
l'avis conforme pour la nomination des
parquets alors que c'est déjà dans la
pratique de tous les garde des sceaux
successifs depuis 2009 et que pour nous
cette réforme constitutionnelle appelé
évidemment un ensemble de mesures vers
l'indépendance mais également vers la
contrepartie de cette année pendant ce
qui n'était pas dans le texte du garde
des sceaux à savoir la responsabilité
des magistrats pour nos ambitionner de
rendre la justice indépendante
c'est aussi la débarrasser une fois pour
toutes de cette dérive pernicieuse de
politisation syndicale de lamastre il
faudra d'une manière ou d'une autre
tourner la page de cette histoire de
politisation syndicales et faire en
sorte que les syndicats qui sont un fait
constitutionnel sur lequel pas question
de revenir se préoccupe de questions
relatives au fonctionnement de la
justice et non pas à des questions
d'ordre purement politique et surtout de
politique pénale
ce n'est pas d'ailleurs la simple charte
de déontologie
les cellules enfin le conseil chargé
d'appliquer une charte déontologique y
va en l'espèce changer les choses
nous sommes pour istres une magistrature
responsable indépendante et neutre
nous considérons que il faudra aussi
émettre un avis très négatif à ce
dispositif qui quelque part à un parfum
de scandale il faut bien le reconnaître
et qui est arrivé au détour de ce texte
c'est la prescription triennale pour les
sanction disciplinaire des magistrats
alors qu'on est en train d'étendre la
prescription pénale de 3 à 6 ans pour
l'ensemble des infractions
donc on voit bien qu'ils cela veut
protéger c'est un petit peu une
prescription je dirais sur mesure qui ne
se souvient de la lamentable affaire du
mur des cons qui serait donc touché par
cette prescription si ce texte est
d'adopter définitivement sur le plan
disciplinaire
voilà l'essentiel de ce que nous
proposerons dans le courant du mois de
juin puisque le projet des républicains
sera soumis un conseil national le 2
juillet de voulons une justice
indépendante réfléchir à l'architecturé
également plus système judiciaire on
voit bien la montée en puissance du juge
des libertés de la détention qui est une
bonne chose
on voit bien la montée en puissance qui
est une bonne chose aussi des parquets
notamment depuis la dernière loi sur le
crime organisé
mais à côté de cela il faut aussi
prévoir des dispositifs qui assure les
droits de la défense qui assure aussi le
respect du principe de la présomption
d'innocence je vous remercie
bonjour thibault le flop de la chaîne
parlementaire
peut-être une question pour monsieur
avec à propos de l'euro vu que vous
travaillez sur les questions liées au
terrorisme
on parle beaucoup des fanzone vous au
vue des auditions vous avez mené
peut-être avez-vous abordé cette
question pensez vous que les fans zones
sont un risque dont l'état pourrait se
passer pour l'organisation de l'euro
alors c'est un sujet qui est évidemment
très difficile
il s'agit de prendre toutes les
précautions faut-il aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction
la question de mon point de vue en tant
que président de commission denquête
effectivement reste entièrement posée on
a vu que les systèmes de sécurité au
stade de france était encore tout à fait
perfectible nous allons nous retrouver
dans une situation de deux grandes
expositions nous sommes une cible nous
le savons j'aurai l'occasion de poser
je peux vous le dire plus précisément
toutes ces questions le jour de
l'audition ouverte à la presse du
ministre d'intérieur monsieur bernard
cazeneuve dans le cas de la commission
denquête donc qui aura lieu le 2 juin au
matin et nous aborderons évidemment
cette question qui est une question très
très importante
bonjour thomas bihel france info je
reviens sur cette question parce qu'elle
est elle est évidemment très importante
et alain juppé qui est le président d
des villes hôtes
on a parlé il ya trois semaines à moi en
disant qu'il vaut mieux avoir des
fanzone justement très sécurisées plutôt
que laisser en quelque sorte des
supporters livrés à eux mêmes dans les
centres villes des grandes villes qui
vont accueillir ces matches on a
l'impression que la position est pas du
tout arrêter dans votre camp politique
et notamment hier nicolas sarkozy au jt
de tf1 a plutôt semblé contre les fans
zone en disant que c'était à priori pas
la bonne solution au sein du parti
qu'elle quelle ligne se détache pour
l'instant alors il ya effectivement la
position qui consiste à dire en crète et
fan zone sécurisée
si on ne crée pas assez fan zone
sécurisée ça va être la porte ouverte à
des petites fentes jaune partout la
position si on me demandait ma position
moi je considère compte tenu du niveau
de la menace qu'il faudrait purement et
simplement interdire ses fans zone c'est
ma position première mais j'entends bien
que c'est une question qui est très
difficile il n'y a pas de véritables
lignes on peut dire aujourd'hui
là dessus je pense que la réflexion doit
se poursuivre dans les semaines qui
viennent
mais encore une fois la décision
appartient évidemment aux responsables
chargés de la sécurité aujourd'hui mais
encore faut-il qu'on l'ait toutes les
garanties de sécurité
et moi je vois pas franchement je vois
pas comment entre 120 130 150 mille
personnes rassemblées au champ de mars
au pied la tour eiffel on peut assurer
qu'il n'y aura pas de risque zéro
c'est l'inquiétude que nous pouvons
avoir mais juste ça veut dire que si on
supprime les fans zone on interdit
également les règles un temps les autres
rassemblements bien juste pour préciser
sur la ligne faut pas voir non plus de
deux divisions lier n'a pas la position
d'alain juppé de dire on a ces lieux
sécurisés et préventivement sécurisé et
on sait en amont comment ça se passe
effectivement dans un dans un monde
idéal c'est l'idéal
mais ce qu'a voulu rappeler nicolas
sarkozy avec justesse hier soir sait où
on en est où
qu'est ce qui nous garantit que les
forces de sécurité seront 10 sport est
disponible et opérationnel
comment s'est organisée à l'échelle du
pays et c'est dans cette perspective
georges durs à 7
cette audition et toutes ces questions
que l'opposition unie d'ailleurs se doit
de poser parce que c'est maintenant que
ça doit se poser est ce dire et non pas
une fois leur aux initiés alors qu'est
ce qu'une économie cette fois la loi
sympa ça sape 2 arrive bientôt donc
à l'assemblée le ps devrait déposer un
amendement pour limiter les salaires des
grands patrons à 100 smic est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut une loi pour
limiter les salaires des grands patrons
bon y aille
il ya une double approche possible sur
ces sur ces questions là d'abord
fondamentalement moi c'est tout ce qui
donne l'impression de l'excès du hors
sol du déconnecté est insupportable aux
yeux d'un grand nombre de nos
compatriotes et c'est légitime que
l'ensemble de la puissance publique
tente de trouver une solution en même
temps si on est réaliste concret
pragmatique et si l'on reprend les
propos d'eric woerth
est ce que c'est à la puissance publique
et est ce qu'elle est en capacité
d'intervenir
comment et jusqu'où on commence la voix
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait spontanément
et je pensais la position quasi unanime
du peuple français qui une sorte de bon
sens qui préside dans les grandes
entreprises et qu'il y ait une logique
liée à une valeur qui était beaucoup
trop oubliée dans notre pays qu'est la
valeur du mérite qu'un grand patron
bénéficie d'une grande rémunération si
ça grandes entreprises réalisent de
grands bénéfices et apporte un grand
nombre de bien-être un grand nombre de
travailleurs
tout le monde est pour
la question permanente c'est ces
polémiques à répétition depuis trop
longtemps
un peu de stock yonne un peu de
parachute doré
un peu beaucoup et beaucoup trop de
salaire qui souvent sont en décalage
avec la réalité
moi ma position je suis pas
parlementaire
ces deux et de dire qui devrait y avoir
une logique presque mécanique avec la
réussite de l'entreprise
il faut que les grandes entreprises
s'adaptent à la réalité que portent au
quotidien les petites et moyennes
entreprises
un artisan un commerçant un entrepreneur
de pme et de tpe
si ça marche améliore sa rémunération
et si ça marche mal ou moins bien et le
premier pénalisé dans sa rémunération
on aimerait je pense que c'est le sens
vers lequel les républicains devront
aller dans les prochains mois et les
prochaines années c'est de créer les
conditions d'une logique liée à la
valeur du mérite
ce qui est insupportable aux yeux de nos
compatriotes est-ce que nous défendrons
c'est que parfois des rémunérations
soient décidées souvent dans le secret
sans aucune transparence ni avec des
conseils d'administration ni avec les
assemblées générales et ne répondent pas
aux critères du bon sens de la santé
économique et financière de l'entreprise
et de la réalité que vivent au quotidien
les travailleurs lorsque vous aurez
réhabiliter la valeur du mérite de la
justice de la justesse et du bon sens y
compris dans le domaine des
rémunérations alors je pense que ces
polémiques s'éteindront d'elle-même
comme d'habitude 20 comme d'habitude si
le bon sens devrait prévaloir
si ça n'est pas le cas est ce que le
législateur peut intervenir et comment
peut-il intervenir
moi ma réponse personnelle je dis bien
personnelle parce que
je vais pas engager le ma famille
politique sur cette thématique
si les syndicats patronaux et
malheureusement ce ne semble pas être le
cas à l'heure où nous parlons
si les grandes entreprises ne sont pas
capables de s'autoréguler
je ne vois pas pourquoi la puissance
publique donc dont c'est le rôle de
quasi génétique s'interdirait
d'intervenir mais là encore pas à
l'issue d'une polémique pas dans
l'ambiance parfois caricaturale d'une
polémique mais avec une grille de
lecture juste et de long terme qui est
le principe autour du principe que je
viens de rappeler vous êtes il ne peut
pas y avoir de plafond pour une
rémunération sauf si elle est cette
rémunération totalement
disproportionnées par rapport à la
réalité et à la santé et à la réussite
financière économique et sociale de
l'entreprise personnes en france sauf
les idéologues ne s'opposerait à l'idée
qu'un patron qui développe à l'infini
son entreprise et qui en fait un fleuron
mondial qui célèbre et qui vante le
patriotisme économique français au
niveau international soit rémunéré à la
hauteur de son talent et de ses
réussites personnes la vérité c'est que
l'ensemble des polémiques que nous
vivons dans notre pays depuis très
longtemps sont liées au décalage
donc moi je souhaite personnellement
qu'on puisse imaginer rapidement sur le
plan législatif une cohérence entre la
santé économique financière et sociale
d'une entreprises et la rémunération de
ses dirigeants
à l'image de ce qui se passe au
quotidien sans loi obligatoire pour
l'ensemble des dirigeants des pme et des
tpe dans notre pays
juste ce jeu permet de votre complété
j'espère que personne n'est dupe non
plus de cette affaire parce que si le
gouvernement actuellement met sur la
table cette discussion qui est le
serpent de mer ça fait quand même des
années qu'on en parle c'est pourquoi
c'est pour détourner l'attention
qui cela concerne-t-il quelques patrons
donc on nous dit on va faire un débat
national et une loi pour quelques cas et
comme guillaume le dit très bien il ya
des tas de domaines dans l'activité
économique qu'on peux vous citer à par
paquets qui se règlent par ce qu'on
appelle l'autorégulation donc nous
croyons en l'intelligence
nous croyons comme tu l'as dit que
évidemment le salaire du patron doit
être proportionnée aux résultats dudit
patron comme le salaire de zlatan et
proportionnée le nombre de buts qu'il
met tout ça est très logique et qui se
posent la question du salaire de zatta
d'entre nous je n'ai jamais entendu
parler ce débat sauf quand il a fallu
leur prendre 75%
oui absolument et on a vu rapidement que
finalement les footballeurs seraient
seraient épargnés par cette disposition
est évidemment terrible et le vrai sujet
c'est que le gouvernement utilise cette
affaire pour détourner l'attention
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le vrai débat en
france c'est quoi c'est la
désindustrialisation
c'est le chômage de masse c'est tous ces
français qui ne peuvent pas retrouver un
travail ou retrouver tout simplement où
le salaire des grands patrons enfin
voyez le gouvernement et spécialistes
pour trouver des dérivatifs à
l'attention celle au fumage absolument
si le filmage gouvernement tant d'autres
questions est juste un commentaire pour
revenir sur la contestation à propos de
la loi les conneries on vous en avait
parlé rapidement notamment de la
situation des pénuries des raffineries
on parle aussi depuis quelques heures de
l'enclos probable dans le mouvement des
laitiers et peut-être de la filière
porcine
comment vous un commentaire là dessus
comment vous analyser cette situation
qui risque de s'étendre à d'autres
secteurs maintenant il ya une semaine on
s'attendait pas encore à l'entrée dans
le mouvement de certains pans de
l'activité et la cie les agriculteurs
également rentrer dans le mouvement
risque d'être dans quelque chose
d'encore plus bloquer très très
clairement on voit très bien que dans ce
sujet c'est le lait et puis demain
d'autres activités c'est l'illustration
de l'absence totale de pilotes
nous sommes un pays qui n'est plus
piloter ça s'est traduit par nuit debout
qui
assez dégradé les violences contre les
policiers vous avez vu que le
gouvernement à dire regardez il ya cinq
meneurs qui vont être jugés 130
policiers blessés et cinq meneurs qui
sont poursuivies et le gouvernement en
fait un communiqué de victoire
la corrélation ne me paraît pas être
évidente entre les 130
d'un côté les 5 de l'autre maintenant le
carburant alors qu'on nous dit la
communication officielle du gouvernement
c'est à dire y'a pas de problème donc on
est sur le ça va mieux ça va bien et
puis le lait et peut-être demain
d'autres activités donc la vraie
question c'est qui gouverne la france
qui est en charge des intérêts du pays
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la réponse
oui c'est exactement ça il ya plein de
l'imposture est la conséquences
profondes de l'impuissance publique
c'est à dire que fondamentalement le
pouvoir est fondé à avoir le pouvoir et
le problème aujourd'hui en france c'est
que le pouvoir n'a plus le pouvoir et
que la puissance publique est devenue
l'impuissance publique
on le voit sur toutes les thématiques ça
a commencé depuis longtemps on l'avait
vécu avec la sphère leonarda bien sûr
les agriculteurs
moi je suis un élu du monde rural le
vivent au quotidien j'étais tout le
week-end chez moi en sologne avec un
comice agricole sa n'a d'ailleurs rien à
voir profondément avec la loi elle
connerie ne croyons pas une seule
seconde si certains agriculteurs
s'associe par exemple à des blocages
dans les jours les semaines qui viennent
que c'est un lien quelconque avec à l'ol
comme riz puisque eux nos agriculteurs
sont des hommes et des femmes de bon
sens et ont bien compris que dans cette
loi il n'y avait plus rien la vérité
c'est qu'ils veulent dire aux français
et surtout aux dirigeants politiques
ça suffit les commentaires et les
constats vous êtes dans l'incapacité de
régler au quotidien nos problèmes et
d'apporter des solutions concrètes
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent les
agriculteurs vous en est ou de la levée
de l'embargo russe que vous nous
promettez depuis des mois et des mois
je me souviens encore d'un grand
discours de manuel valls au mois de
novembre
c'est imminent on est au mois de mai à
la fin du mois de mai toujours rien oui
il nous faut lever l'embargo russe
c'est fondamental
et surtout pour les professions que vous
avez cités tout à l'heure oui exactement
qu'en est il du moratoire sur les normes
attendues par l'ensemble des paysans
dans notre pays
qu'en est il de la baisse des charges
sociales à part quelques saupoudrages
ici ou là toujours rien qu'en est-il
d'une grande politique des circuits de
proximité pour garantir une trésorerie
pn à nos agriculteurs sur le territoire
moi je suis élu dans ma dans ma région
la région centre val de loire on
continue à avoir des blocages juridique
administratif à la mise en oeuvre de ce
principe du bon sens qui permettrait
d'approvisionner je l'espère 50% puis
100% un jour de toutes nos cantines
scolaires de toutes nos restauration
collective avec des produits régionaux
et locaux ces sacs attendent
très concrètement les agriculteurs dans
notre pays et qui viendront peut-être se
mêler aux contestations mais c'est
fondamentalement pas la même
contestation que ces minorités syndicale
agissante hyper conservatrice comme la
cgt incapable de comprendre que le monde
a changé le monde a changé et le monde
requièrent des solutions nouvelles et ce
n'est pas avec l'imposture et l'enfumage
de la loi elle comme riz qui a été vidée
de sa substance qui fut écrite peut-être
à l'origine par quelques hommes et
femmes éclairé mais qui fut très vite
qu'ils furent très vite rattrapé par la
par la patrouille a entre autres par la
plume conjointe et de la cgt et de
l'unef syndicat minoritaire de gauche et
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il n'ya plus rien
dans cette loi la question du lait est
aussi une question européenne
monsieur le foll a participé à 20% des
conseils agriculture il a été absent à
80% de ces réunions
comment voulez vous défendre les
intérêts des agriculteurs français quand
vous n'allez pas physiquement au conseil
donc le pl absence de pilotage national
se traduit aussi par une absence en
europe c'est une question vraiment clé
j'y reviens ce que c'est comme l'une des
informations importantes de la matinée
du point de vue notre famille politique
nous demandons immédiatement au
gouvernement de prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour libérer les
raffineries mette fin au blocus et si
nécessaire mettre en oeuvre des
réquisitions via le code général des
collectivités territoriales en lien avec
les préfets pour libérer dans les
meilleurs délais les raffineries en
france et ce qu'attendent une majorité
de nos compatriotes c'est ce
qu'attendent toutes celles et ceux qui
veulent travailler et c'est là encore
une politique de bon sens que nous
appelons de nos voeux
christophe fraga pour rfi bruno le maire
valérie pécresse ont critiqué le
déplacement manuel valls est ce que vous
condamnez également le fait qu'ils se
déplacent alors que la france est en
crise comme ils l'ont dit chacun va
donner son oui tout simplement le oui et
non c'est à dire que oui on aimerait que
manuel valls soit aux commandes de
l'état et qu'il prenne des décisions
plutôt que d'organiser des réunions
publiques microscopique égocentré si
possible d'ailleurs dans son fief temps
ses sympathisants et ses partisans sont
réduits à peau de chagrin depuis
quelques semaines et quelques mois qu'il
prenne des décisions
il est le premier ministre de la france
alors moi je considère qu'avec les
moyens modernes de communication ou
qu'on soit dans le monde
on doit pouvoir prendre des décisions
fortes
mais bruno le maire et valérie pécresse
n'ont pas tort que de mettre en lumière
à travers ce déplacement à l'étranger
cette incapacité chronique est désormais
structurelle du premier ministre qui
ressemble de plus en plus aux précédents
la république qui l'a nommé cette
incapacité à prendre des décisions vous
imaginez le ras-le-bol considérable du
peuple français par rapport à ces
événements quotidiens qui donne
l'impression qu'il n'ya plus ni pilote
ni cap ni capitaine la vérité c'est que
depuis plusieurs mois la france est
orpheline de son président et de son
gouvernement
il n'y a plus personne pour décider et
les seuls porte parole on en voit
régulièrement dans les médias
effectivement
pour nous dire du lundi ça va mieux au
vendredi ça va bien alors que chacun
sait que ça va très mal et très mal dans
tous les domaines
j'ajoute que s'il est important que la
france au niveau du premier ministre
soit présente dans cette région du monde
ça c'est absolument incontestable et à
ma connaissance il n'y a pas de vacance
du pouvoir
brisant un public est à paris louise de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve et à paris
donc le pouvoir est absolument en mesure
de prendre et le cabinet de manuel valls
bien entendu et l'a1 de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent pour
effectivement permettre
l'approvisionnement en essence de nos
concitoyens donc que prémunissait en
israël personne ne critiquera mais
entendu au contraire c'est une bonne
chose mais il n'y a pas de vacance du
pouvoir et les décision doit être prise
dernier point sur cette affaire le
premier ministre en israël
c'est aussi son rôle mais quand il y va
c'est à la fois effectivement s'assurant
qu'en france ça ne soit pas le bordel on
sait que celle là mais aussi silva en
israël à charlie bardot la conséquence
pour les français est assez similaire en
revanche et silva en israël c'est aussi
pour obtenir quelque chose
je n'ai pas connaissance d'un résultats
très probants de son voyage à quoi son
voyage at il servi comme vous le savez
un xxi ème plan de paix est relancé et
là l'idée géniale des participants et de
discuter sans les israéliens sont les
palestiniens je pense qu'avec ça
effectivement ça devrait avancer donc
nous posons aussi la question pourquoi
est il est allé là bas et qu'il rende
des comptes
parce que s'il y va sans rien obtenir
son faire avancer la position de la
france dans cette région qui est une
région fondamental pour nous et en même
temps en laissant les casseurs cassé
convenait que madame pécresse n'a pas
totalement tort
merci beaucoup